is um now all of white's pawns are on  light squares on white squares so there  will be easy meat  easy pickings for that uh for the black  bishop um black's bishop will  win all those remaining pawns uh  levanoroni he's just making moves  because he doesn't want to resign yet  and okay nobody's ever won a game by  resigning but  um he knows that there's nothing left to  do in this game  you can just see it on his body language  yes the monaro onion is  giving up very soon yeah and he has  resigned  there we have it rajabov has won the  first match  wow okay such a tense day we had three  draws  and then coming to the final game of the  first  final match timorajabo is the winner of  that and that means he is the winner  of day one in the finals and they are  keeping calm we can see it on the  webcams now both players  but what's going on inside the the heads  now yuanka